hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast automated variant
classifications encouragin clinical
insight shows near-perfect coordinates
with clinvar expert panel assessments
presented by dr. Jennifer Poitras a
principal genome scientists at kiya Jen
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by kaya Jen for more
information about our sponsor visit them
at wwk Jen calm before we begin I want
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type those
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation just click on the ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credit tab located
on the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit without
further ado please join me in welcoming
our presenter dr. Jennifer Poitras I
will now turn the presentation over to
her welcome dr. portress thank you for
the introduction and for the opportunity
to speak with you all today um so today
I'll be talking about our occassions
clinical decision support tool the
knowledge-based underlying it and
focusing on how we leverage that
information to automate ACMG variant
classifications and more specifically
how these classifications show
near-perfect concordance with clinvar
expert panel assessments
so in the way of a legal disclaimer the
tool I'm discussing today as I said is a
clinical decision support tool and isn't
attended for diagnosis and this message
is meant to convey that so for today's
agenda first I'll go through an
introduction to the kyochon knowledge
base and introduce our kaijin clinical
insight interpret tool and demonstrate
how the knowledge base underlying it
enables rapid and accurate variant
interpretation we'll also see how
automated variant classification is
utilized by invoking all the ACMG rules
to align with the guidelines and some
benchmarks that show the value of the
tools
so today we're really focusing as you
can see at the end of the pipeline with
the red box around it or the tertiary
analysis or interpretation but just to
put things in context the goals of
kaijin is to take you from sample to
insight where we offer a variety of DNA
RNA extraction kits as well as library
preparation kits to prepare you to
perform your next-generation sequencing
once you've generated your fast queue
files you can easily feed those into the
biomedical genomics work bench which is
our graphical user interface application
that's truly a one stop shop for NGS
analysis empowering the scientist or
clinician with limited bioinformatics
knowledge to map reach the reference and
for the purposes of today's discussion
call variance to produce a VCF file
which brings me to the topic that I'll
cover today and how we can leverage our
curated content within our downstream
tools particularly kaijin clinical
insight which is our clinical decision
support platform to rapidly distill the
list of variants down to one or a
handful that are likely implicated in
the patient's disease so the end result
our output from QC I will be a report
with relevant variant information
including automatically computed ACMG
pathogenicity which you can see on the
left as this EP 300 variant is
pathogenic and also it's just including
citations in the second page that the
user has added that we've curated within
the knowledge base and this is really
facilitated through having all the
content listed here within the knowledge
base and that's really the focus of
today's discussion so today will be
mainly talking about hereditary disease
indications but I just wanted to point
out that this is a platform agnostic NGS
interpretation tool meaning you can
perform your sequencing on any platform
you like and just take the VCF file and
for the somatic indications we use our
curated content to peer the variance by
the amp cheering classification system
in terms of actionability and also the
using the ACMG guidelines for both
hereditary panels and also clinical
exome indication which brings me as a
nice egg way to my next slide so just
into as an introduction to the ACMG
guidelines for those in the audience
that may not know this system several
years ago that ACMG or American College
of medical genetics created this
evidence-based framework for guidelines
of variant interpretation so rules
falling into various evidence categories
that favor a variant as benign or
pathogenic along this continuum
you know from left to right with also
different strength categories you can
see listed at the top of each column so
what the variant scientists will do is
they'll look to see you know which of
these criteria does my variant meet and
those criteria in aggregate classify
ovarian as benign likely benign ovarian
of uncertain significance likely
pathogenic or pathogenic depending on
the combination of rules applied and you
can read more about this framework in
the publication down to the right
so identifying which rules to apply to
interpret variants is no small
undertaking so many resources are
necessary for gathering that information
and I've just highlighted a handful here
so the variant scientists would be to
sift through variant specific
publications from pubmed check public
and proprietary databases to see you
know if my candidate gene or variant has
been seen before in my disease context
and also looking at in silico predictors
as well as public databases to look at
allele frequency
so what guy gene has really done is
simplified this process by putting it
all in one place but there are two major
challenges that a variant scientist
faces when you know having to sift
through all this information one is of
efficiency because this is very
laborious and time-consuming and the
second is of accuracy because a person
you know might miss something having to
look in all these different places so
what Kyon's done is simplify this
process by centralizing it and putting
it all in one location that we know as
our knowledge base
um so as I said we put all this
information and aggregated it into
what's known as the ingenuity or really
kiya jinn knowledge based so for the
past 20 or so years we've had MD and PhD
level scientists manually curating the
literature and inputting findings in a
controlled and meticulous way beyond the
literature we also incorporate data from
third party sources like clinvar OMA and
clinical trials.gov
to come together and build this ontology
such that we have a rich resource of
gene gene and gene phenotype
relationships that you'll see a little
later in the presentation will enable us
to easily pull out variants of interest
from a clinical exome additionally you
know these findings are what are tied to
those ACMG rules that invoke them during
the variant interpretation process so
we've talked a lot conceptually about
our content but let's look at the
breadth of coverage in terms of numbers
so our knowledge base not only contains
two of the most widely used databases of
clinically relevant variants as you can
see hgmd in the green or sorry gray
circle and you know routines in clinvar
in the sort of periwinkle circle but you
can appreciate how much value is added
from our unique curated content from the
literature as on the left here seeing
that we're adding 121 percent more genes
on top of what's already contained
within hgmd in clinvar and on the right
you can see that we're adding 159
percent more variants just from curating
from the literature including are on top
of what's contained in hgmd and clinvar
so you see the value that are you know
manually curated content has added and
just to show you how this information is
presented here's an example of how these
variant specific publications are
curated into findings so there are three
findings associated with this
publication where we can see this
variant is associated with a particular
disease EP 300 is a variant in the EP
300 gene is associated with Reuben skin
tabby syndrome and within a particular
population as you can see the El
Salvadorian population down below in the
last finding so ultimately is these
findings that are used to invoke the
ACMG rules
and compute pathogenicity
so now that I've introduced the cottage
and knowledge-based and how the content
is used to automatically classify
variants let's look at some benchmarks
that show how qci addresses and major
challenges faced in variant
interpretation
so I mentioned in the beginning that
there are two main challenges faced by
the variant scientists or geneticists in
mining and utilizing all available
information to classify variants so now
I'll touch on a couple of benchmarking
studies that demonstrate how kaijin
clinical insight addresses these
challenges of efficiency and accuracy so
first we'll start with efficiency so
this is study performed by counsel and
counsel is a health technology company
that offers carrier screening and
hereditary cancer risk assessment so at
last year's American Society of Human
Genetics meeting counsel presented their
findings in a poster from an evaluation
they performed and the goal of this
evaluation was to assess whether
utilization of Kyon's variant specific
bibliographies within qci could match
the level of accuracy and quality of
counsels more time-intensive manual
article selection approach they looked
at around 2000 variants they reviewed
over a three-month period and in the
graph on the left you can appreciate the
comprehensive nature of our content
where there is a large amount of overlap
between our variant specific citations
and those present in the council house
database and there is a huge amount of
you know in the center bar you can see
there's a huge amount of unique
information in the kaijin knowledge base
alone
and not only does qci provide a
comprehensive content resource but the
centralized content reduced the time
spent searching for variant specific
publications significantly and this is
made most obvious from looking at the
median where the search time is reduced
in a graph on the right by an order of
magnitude when using qci and these are
represented by the yellow bars
so overall council demonstrated that
there was a clear value in adopting qci
and they've now made it a key component
of their variant assessment on pipeline
now we address efficiency well the other
challenge we mentioned right is accuracy
so I mentioned that we are uniquely
positioned because of arterial content
to invoke all 28 a CNG rules but how
accurately are we in doing so so to test
this we took expert panel assess Bravo
one and Bravo two variants from clinvar
which you can see in the top window and
put those through QC I to compare the
Enigma assessments with the
classifications and QC I so I should
mention that enigma is the expert panel
that is extremely dedicated to
determining the clinical significance of
bracha 1 and 2 variants as well as other
known or suspected hereditary breast
cancer predisposition genes so in this
study that I'll be speaking about today
they were over at the time the study was
performed just over 6,000 of these
variants and in this particular example
you can see that this is an example of a
concordant variant where the variant was
classified as pathogenic in qci and was
also called pathogenic by the expert
panel and what we found was actually you
know rather astounding so in this graph
the green bar represents classifications
made by chitin or qci the green bar
represents those made by the expert
panel so you can see that and you can
see at the top of the graphs is N equals
6135 as those are the number of variants
that we benchmarked here on the 80 1.7
percent of those were perfectly
concordant between qci and the enigma
expert panel and then when we move to
the right you can see the 17 an
additional 17 point 8 7 percent we're
different but those differences should
not affect medical management as you can
see for example likely benign versus
benign which shouldn't affect medical
management of the patient so when we
take those two together we can see at
the top where Britain 99.6% there's
ninety nine point six percent
concordance with respect to clinical
actionability when we take these
together which is you know rather
incredible for you know a computer
algorithm so now we can also look at on
the right there is very small percentage
so 0.43% of difference
that might affect medical management so
those are the key sources of those
discrepancies fall into a couple of
different categories so one is enigma
specific variant scoring criteria
outside the classic ACMG framework so
for example there are pieces of
information or data like posterior
probability for example that are not
part of the ACMG framework then enigma
does use so we don't have you know so
because the algorithm doesn't have
control over that because they're using
information outside the framework
additionally on there's some functional
studies that we're not considered by
enigma and we'll go through an example
where we highlight that in a second
so first let's just go through an
example of a concordant variant so here
you can see this particular barakatu
variant was considered pathogenic or
classified as pathogenic in qci and also
pathogenic by the clinvar group and I
just wanted to point out you know
exactly what this looks like within qci
so you can see that we show you which
rules and you can see the criteria ID of
PBS 1 for example in PS 3 going down so
we show you you know which criteria were
actually invoked and then additionally
to the right in the evidence column we
could show you you know how many
publications actually are underlying
that particular rule that invoked it and
you can go and investigate those and
we'll do that now so we look here we see
that PS 4 was triggered now this is
actually not trivial to do because this
rule is looking at you know is there the
prevalence of this variant enriched or
statistically significant in the disease
population over controls so to do that
you need clinical cases which we've
curated from the literature and then
perform a Fisher's exact test and you
can see in this red box that we actually
have done all that and provide you with
the p-value and since the p-value is
significant we invoke PS 4
you'll also notice in the evidence
column that there are 24 publications
that were used to collect those
individuals and you can actually go in
and investigate
you know those 24 publications to see
which individuals how many individuals
were in each of those publications is it
a family study or an individual so we
keep everything extremely per
transparent within qci to provide you
with all the evidence that was necessary
in coming to this assessment
um so now we'll look at a discordant
variant okay so for this particular
synonymous variant qci or sorry the
enigma panel called this likely benign
and you can see in the evidence that
they're citing an in silico prediction
and that's the evidence that they're
providing
however in QCI we actually call this
variant likely pathogenic and this is
using of course the standard ACMG
framework and you can see in the
evidence column I've circled the two
because this is there are two curated
functional studies that indicate this
variant results in a splicing defect so
we've actually curated functional
studies that you know we're not
considered by enigma and this is
actually a good point to bring up right
here is that you know the enigma doesn't
actually consider functional studies
currently because they're still you know
within the group they're debating you
know what kinds of functional studies
actually merit you know inclusion
invariant scoring for Bravo one and two
so what we're doing is we're just
providing you with all the possible
information so you can make the judgment
call of what functional studies you'd
like to include you know we've curated
these two functional studies that are
then pushing this into the likely
pathogenic category and what I
investigated them on these publications
actually do say that this particular
variant leads to a defect in splicing in
a mini gene assay when I went through
and looked at it so it shows you the
power and the importance of our curated
content in kind of evaluating all the
pathogenicity of a variance
so in summary of these benchmark studies
so a curated bibliography from the
council study our reduced time spent
searching for variant specific
publications by an order of magnitude so
that addresses the efficiency issue
that's faced by the variant scientist
also in the Enigma study qci automated
ACMG classification of over 6,000 bracha
one and two variants resulted in 99.6%
concordance with the enigma expert panel
various variant assessments with respect
to clinical actionability and the
sources of this discourse as I said were
due to kinda nuances and the enigma
scoring framework and finally as always
we're continuing to refine the ACMG at a
classification algorithm in concordance
with the sequence variant interpretation
working groups recommendations to ensure
the highest level of accuracy in
alignment with ACMG standards
so now we've seen how automated ACMG
classification works and proven its
accuracy but let's look at a practical
example where we identify a causal
variant from a clinical exome sample so
just briefly to discuss the clinical
exome framework or workflow so in this
particular example you can see in the
pedigree on the right we've got two
unaffected parents and infected son and
this patient has a constellation of
features but no clear diagnosis which is
typically the case for clinical exomes
so you can see that the pedigree is
shaded with these five different
phenotypes and all this clinical
information is you know put into a
simple JSON file in this case phenotypes
was used to contain all the clinical
data necessary from all of these
patients in the relator sorry is family
members and the relationships within it
on top of that in addition to that JSON
file with the phenotype data we bring in
the VCF files in this case we have three
VCF files one for each individual but we
do support you know beyond trios also
more complex family structures as well
so by bringing on the clinical data as
well as the variant data into qci we can
then use information in the knowledge
base to filter that down including
allele frequencies predicted gelateria
sness is the variant in the proband or
not to fill that down to a more
reasonable list and finally arrived at
our variant interpretation so we'll be
using a phenotype driven ranking
algorithm to rank these variants where
you can see we've added those five
phenotypes that were in the JSON file in
the pro bands and those five phenotypes
appear as little rectangles going across
so all five phenotypes are overlapping
with Rubinstein's kv syndrome type one
based on curated information in the
knowledge base and additionally EP 300
is known to associate with Rubinstein kV
syndrome type one so you can see how EP
300 on this variant at EP 300 is ranked
at the top based on our phenotype driven
ranking
so to just go through this a little more
deeply so first you can see I've drawn a
box on the right around this
intellectual disability and ACMG 59 view
so here we've created some virtual
panels to subset the genes in the
analysis so in this case the referring
physician was concerned that maybe in
this defined list of about 2,000 genes
associated with intellectual disability
the patient has a variant in one of
those genes so they wanted to see and
look at those genes separately as well
as the ACMG 59 genes to see if there
were any incidental findings so in this
particular case you can see this red the
EP 300 gene at the top which ends up
being our causal variant and I'll show
you that in the next slide that ends up
being present within the intellectual
disability sub view so you do have the
ability to set up your own virtual
panels as well
but as far as the phenotype driven
ranking algorithm goes here again you
can see that these gray boxes in the
third column over where it says
candidate disease so those five
rectangles each represent one of the
phenotypes is displayed in the patient
and you can see in the first row that
all five of them are present in
consistent with Rubenstein TV syndrome
which those connections are in the
curated content in the knowledge base
additionally EB 300 is known to be
associated with proven seen TV syndrome
and for this reason that pathogenic
variant which is also automatically
computed and classified as pathogenic is
our number one ranked variant you can
look at other information in the table
to kind of distill down or bolster this
analysis so for example I can see in the
mode of inheritance column that this is
a dominant disorder and then when I look
at the genotypes of the parents and the
program this is again consistent so here
in the proband column you can see that
this EP 300 variant is heterozygous and
present in the program but is absent in
the unaffected parents which again makes
sense furthermore stating or showing us
that this EP status genic EP 300 variant
is causal for this disorder
dig in a little further which you go to
the variant details tab and this is
where we're shown as I showed before
where the which criteria were actually
invoked which ACMG rules were invoked
and I can review the evidence there as
well as well as looking at the
bibliography where I've drawn this arrow
so this will show me all the curated
content I no longer have to go to PubMed
search for eg 300 specific publications
and I can add those to the report as
shown here so there are 20 references at
both a gene and variant level that
associate ep 300 with a particular
disorder on that I can investigate or
choose to add to my report
so all in all the skies and knowledge
base within qci facilitates a number of
things is extremely powerful because of
all the curated content so we've just
shown how I can be used to rapidly on
filter and also prioritize variants from
a clinical exome also we use this
curated content to uniquely position us
to automate ACMG classification as I
mentioned driven by this extensively
curated content and we showed in two
different benchmarking studies that this
curated content increases efficiency and
turnaround time and reporting variants
as shown by the council study and then
finally on the yes we can automatically
compute ACMG classifications but we also
do so in a extremely accurate manner so
we've shown as highly concordant with a
brothel one and two variant assessments
of the Klinge an expert panel group
workplace bar on so with that thank you
for your time and I'm happy to take any
questions that you may have
thank you dr. Poitras for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appear on the screen and click that send
button our speaker will follow up with
your questions via email so let's get
started our first question
dr. Porter's is how frequently is the
knowledge base updated ok and that's a
great question so as I mentioned we have
several sources of content so the
content in the literature is actually
updated basically daily or you know we
like to say on a weekly basis so we're
constantly updating that anything that
we're getting from a database such as
clinvar and hgmd or OMM for example
those are all updated on the quarterly
basis
thank you for that we have one more
question coming does the user have the
ability to change the ACMG rule that are
applied yes in fact they do so as I
showed you I'll go back to a couple of
slides so you can see that there are
criteria listed here and you can see the
criteria ideas so there are little X's
next to them where you could delete
those criteria or underneath you can see
the add criterion button initially I
mean additionally you can change the
strengths of those rules as well so
there's a lot of plasticity and
sovereignty that we give the user in
terms of amending those ACMG rules that
are applied Tector pointers thank you
for that informative presentation again
and for your important research I'd also
like to think lab roots and our sponsor
caging for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go and I
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through February 2019 you'll receive an
email from your lab brooch letting you
know when the webcast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now and thank you for joining us
today we hope to see you again soon
bye-bye